and what some people have heard about is
you know a a year ago I had to remove my
brother who was running our basketball
operation at the time okay
and it was kind of an unusual
circumstance because I had to use the
authority that was given to me by my
father to do that and and and the people
dick right and people who are in family
businesses can understand how difficult
that is but it was something that was
really important to my father to keep
the team in the family and I couldn't
see any progress as to how the
basketball side was run and so I brought
Magic Johnson in to run the operation
and I think he's done a good job in the
last 16 17 months and his magic is
pretty fast and he must be just so
charming huh is it just immediate charm
what is it about him you know what it is
it's very interesting because he you
know people kind of compare him with
another Laker great Kobe Bryant and both
equally successful in terms of winning
championships each have won five but
magic had this big smile on his face
yeah the charisma always we saw about
HIV pretty much it seems like you know
you know somebody smiled as well he's he
is he is Ali a natural leader with that
kind of charisma but now that I've I'm
with him in the in the board room and
hearing him make strategy as to how
we're putting our team together he will
continue to smile as he talks about
dissecting the other teams in the league
cutting them apart he is he will he will
make you feel good but he will be like
it was a win yes and now do you think
that he always had this because I'm a
magic that I don't think I'm a I don't
think you could find I never thought
about this I don't think he could find a
person in the world that's probably not
a fan of Magic Johnson you know what I'm
saying like there's just something about
him you almost
I mean you remember what team he played
for the Lakers but you just there's
something about him that makes you feel
good well he he's a worldwide figure and
certainly Muhammad Ali was you know
beloved and and stood really for for so
much in this world and I would say that
Magic has that same kind of of persona
and he's revered all around the world
it's fascinating and suit not but his
business acumen is that something that
he's learned he he is he he's like you
know he wanted to learn everything even
as starring for the Lakers and winning
championships he was wanting to know
more about business and he was like a
sponge he would go and he would pick the
brains of all the the smart people that
he would meet and most importantly my
father and so when he and I are together
you know working strategizing we speak
the same language because we were
basically raised by the same man
you know I my dad bought the team when I
was 17 magic came that same year at age
19 so we're basically the same age and
we learned at the you know the hand of
one of the greatest owners ever most
winningest owners dr. Jerry bass my
father well thanks for watching that
video right there that was a beautiful
little segment I think but of course i'm
partisan to myself but you can move on
to another video right now you can check
on this video or on this video that's
two different options and you can also
subscribe to the channel check on a new
video subscribe to the channel check
subscribe subscribe